So I live in Arizona where it is hot,
or at least warm most of the year,
so my fall winter clothing wardrobe is very very small.
So I ordered some stuff from Shein
because they're having their Black Friday sale.
So here are some of the things I ordered.
I thought that they would be cute
like date night outfits. Um,
I love the idea of like long sleeve dresses that are short with boots.
I think that's so cute! It's comfy.
Maybe if it's cold enough here.
If I get lucky enough I will wear tights under them too.
I will do like a try on haul too.
I'm hoping they get here soon
and I'm really excited to get to dress cozy
for at least a couple months.
Let me know if any of you have ordered these things
and if you like them!